usa el discriminante para indicar el
número y el tipo de soluciones de la
ecuación menos 3x cuadrada más 5 x menos
4 igual a 0 y bueno lo primero que sería
bueno saber es que es el discriminante
de una ecuación cuadrática y para esto
voy a poner aquí la ecuación cuadrática
en forma estándar y también como era la
fórmula cuadrática así que si yo tengo
la ecuación a x cuadrada más bx más c
igual a 0 es una ecuación cuadrática en
su forma estándar y entonces como ya
hemos visto en varios vídeos podemos
decir que las soluciones las obtenemos
con la fórmula cuadrática que era x
igual a menos b más menos la raíz
cuadrada de b cuadrada menos 4 hacemos
todo esto dividido entre dos a ahora
bien lo que quiero que recuerdes es de
la importancia que tiene de cuadrada
menos 4 ac en las soluciones de esta
ecuación cuadrática porque ese cuadrado
menos 4 hace nos indica qué clase de
soluciones vamos a tener todo lo que
está dentro de la raíz cuadrada es muy
importante y es justo esto en lo que es
el discriminante el discriminante es b
cuadrado
4a cm y es bastante importante porque
imagínate que ve cuadrada -4 hace es un
número positivo de cuadrada menos 4 hace
es mayor que 0 si esto es mayor que 0
entonces la raíz de un número mayor que
0 existen los números reales y entonces
esto nos va a decir que tenemos dos
soluciones en los números reales así que
vamos a escribir le vamos a tener dos
raíces reales dos soluciones reales
bueno esto es cuando tenemos b cuadrada
menos 4 hace mayor que 0 el segundo caso
cuando b cuadrada menos 4 ac es igual a
cero es decir que el discriminante sea
igual a 0 importante cuenta que aquí
tendría 0 y entonces la raíz cuadrada de
0 es 0 y solamente me quedaría una
solución de la forma menos b entre 2 a
porque date cuenta que la parte de
arriba de esta fracción solamente me
quedaría menos bien y entonces tenemos
dos raíces iguales o dicho de otra
manera solamente tenemos una solución mi
única solución es menos de entre 2 am
que por cierto es una solución real sólo
podemos pensar como que mis dos
soluciones son soluciones reales o
también lo podemos pensar como que mis
dos soluciones una misma
es esta solución bueno esto en el caso
de que ve cuadrada menos 40 sea igual a
cero por eso es tan importante analizar
el discriminante pero también tenemos el
tercer caso donde b cuadrada menos 4 ac
es menor que cero y si tenemos algo
menor que cero dentro de una raíz
cuadrada entonces la raíz cuadrada de
algo negativo es un número imaginario y
por lo tanto mis raíces se van a ver de
la forma compleja mis raíces son números
complejos porque van a tener una parte
real que es menos b / 2a y además van a
tener una parte imaginaria que es
precisamente la raíz de este número
negativo pero además pasa algo
importantísimo cuando yo tengo que mis
dos soluciones son números complejos
estas soluciones cumplen una
característica bien importante son
complejos conjugados es decir si yo
tengo un número complejo que es solución
de esta ecuación cuadrática entonces el
conjugado de este número complejo
también va a ser una solución de esta
ecuación cuadrática pero bueno vamos a
analizar en este ejemplo cómo se
comporta me discriminante para que yo
sepa cómo van a ser mis soluciones así
que aquí tengo que a vale menos 3 b más
de 5 y se vale
4 entonces ya tengo el valor de bs lo
único que nos falta es sustituir estos
valores en mi discriminante en la
ecuación que tengo de mi discriminante
para saber cómo van a ser mis soluciones
y además para saber qué cantidad de
soluciones tengo así que que me decía el
discriminante de una ecuación cuadrática
pues es de cuadrada menos 4 hacen es
decir 5 al cuadrado menos 4 por aquí
vale menos tres por c que valen menos
414 se vale menos 4 entonces me quedaba
cuadrada es decir 5 al cuadrado menos 4
por a que vale menos 3 por sé que vale
menos 4 y cuánto es esto
pues 5 al cuadrados 25 y aquí me quedan
menos por menos me da más tres por
cuatro me da 12 y 12 por 4 me da 48 pero
con signo negativo menos 48 25 menos 48
esto es lo que vale mi discriminante de
esta ecuación cuadrática que por cierto
cuánto vale 25 menos 48 bueno 25 menos
48 es lo mismo que menos 13 menos 13 no
lo es menos 23 entonces déjenme
corregirlo aquí
-23 que por cierto es un número menor
que cero y esto es lo más importante
porque me está diciendo que mi
discriminante es menor que cero y
entonces estamos en el tercer caso
entonces nos dice que tenemos dos
soluciones y estas dos soluciones son
raíces complejas